life
yes just a moment chairman i'll do that
ready chairman thank you
so good morning um members of vistas and
anybody watching uh this meeting on the
council's live
um youtube channel this morning welcome
to rocha district council's remote
meeting of the licensing and appeals
subcommittee
uh you uh okay so i have a declaration
which i
need to make first of all so um
looking at the agenda for this morning
we've already appointed i've already
taken item
agenda item and one which points the
chairman which was myself
my name is councillor wilkinson i will
introduce all the other members of the
panel will introduce themselves shortly
before we begin uh item two on the
agenda
is declaration of interests now um i
think it's
uh fair for anybody watching this to to
know that there will be
a number of uh members of ruptured
council speaking this morning
uh on this this application who are not
members of the panel
and we it's clear that we have a working
relationship
with those members um but those members
do not have a vote
will not have a decision on the outcome
of this meeting this morning
that will rest in the hands of the three
members of the panel only and you have
our assurances of course that we will
base that decision on the evidence we
hear before us
in conjunction with the licensing
objectives
so good morning to you all uh my name is
councillor wilkinson i'm the chairman
this morning of the licensing appeals
committee
and the other two members of the
committee of you please introduce
yourselves
uh councillor joe macpherson thank you
chairman
council america you need to amuse
yourself sir i apologize
uh i'm do counselor david merrick thank
you very much
um we are joined this morning by
several officers of the council so first
of all we have count we have mr chris
irwin
who is the council's uh legal solicitor
we have um uh sodium worthington and
lauren morris
who are from the council democratic
services department so this committee
will follow procedure set out to
procedural note item
number three on the agenda
the purpose of the hearing today is to
consider an application for a premises
license made by
stephen pegg on behalf of county ales
limited
relating to 16 golden cross parade in
rochford
there is also an application for a
pavement licence in relation to the same
premises
which will be determined today
please could the council's licensing
officer introduce themselves
good morning my name is stephen greener
i am the principal licensing officer for
roger district council
my name is greater do you have any
witnesses you'll be calling this morning
no i'll be not calling any witnesses
today thank you okay thank you
can the applicant please introduce
himself
hi my name is stephen pegg i'm the
applicant for the premises license
for 16 golden cross good morning mr peg
are you calling any witnesses this
morning uh no i won't be like
okay um okay
are there could there any other
responsible authorities please introduce
themselves
i don't think there is anybody this
morning is there because environmental
health have withdrawn so
uh now we have any interest interested
parties i know we have a couple of other
people joining us this morning
uh mr smith can i start with you sir
could you introduce yourself
and your your interest in this
application
my name's john martin i'm not sure what
i'm known as john smith
that's sorry says on the screen mr smith
i know
yes but i'm john martin and i'm
here as an objector okay thank you mr
martin
um and the other two members
councillor gooding you nearly got there
you've muted yourself counselor
good morning i'm councillor julie goodin
and i will be representing residents who
have raised their concerns regarding
the microbrewery proposal thank you
thank you councillor gooding cancer
butcher
you need to amuse yourself as well
councillor butcher
i think council butcher might be having
problems with her internet connection
um right can you hear me counselor
butcher if you can that's it yeah you've
muted yourself
yeah i can hear you sorry i'm i'm having
trouble it's still saying that i'm
i'm waiting to get in but uh you can
obviously hear me now
we can hear you and see you yes yes
can you just introduce yourself and
yours my name is councillor
yes my name's um i'm councillor butcher
i'm representing the residence
okay thank you very much your um your
audio is a bit broken so we have to play
that by ear maybe that we may need to
ask you
to phone in or something so we can hear
you properly but we'll we'll see how
that goes
if you wouldn't mind muting yourself
again please counsel butcher um
okay i think that's everybody so can all
interested parties just confirm they
have received the report anybody has not
received the
agenda or report for today's hearing
good okay so i just remind everybody
that um
uh there is a time limit of 15 minutes
for interested parties which will be
apportioned evenly between
uh all people so please obviously uh
it's less so for you mr peg because
you're the only person speaking for the
application but certainly for the other
three we need to be mindful of each
other to fit it all in within the 15
minutes
now wish to ask mr steven green of the
council's principal licensing officer to
summarize the application for us all
please
good morning thank you very much this
application
is in relation to the grant of a
premises license made under section 17
of the licensing act 2003.
the application was submitted to the
licensing authority
on behalf of county ales limited in
relation to a premises
known as two green bottles 16 golden
cross parade rochard essex
a copy of the original application was
submitted as a part of appendix a
the premises to which the application
relates comprises of a micro pub
with the intention of predominantly
selling craft owls
beers and wines the license ball
activity
and i will ask mr peck to confirm this
is in relation to
the supply of alcohol on and off sales
live music and recorded music under the
regulated
entertainment in relation to
the representations under the
responsible authorities
the police have agreed conditions with
the applicant for the committee to
consider
should the license be granted and as
it has already been raised the
application has been assessed by
environmental health
and they have also now agreed
with the applicant certain conditions
and ask for the committee to consider
these should the application be granted
other persons that have made
representations there are 14
representations received
11 from local residents and free from
local councillors representations
raise concerns in relation to the
following licensing objectives
public safety prevention of crime and
disorder
prevention of public nuisance and a copy
of these representations
have been included within the report
under appendix e
there was also a petition that was also
submitted but unfortunately this didn't
fit the criteria
under the licensing act 2003 and we
could not accept it
under legal implications the provisions
of the licensing act need to be taken
into consideration
the licensing act hearings regulations
2005
the guidance issued under section 182 of
the licensing act
and the statement of licensing policy
approved by full council
for the period of the 31st of january
2020
2021 to the 31st of january 2026.
this all needs to be considered by
members in determining the application
the recommendation under paragraph 8 of
the report
is proposed that the committee resolves
the application with one of the
following
options the grant the application
subject
to such conditions as are consistent
with the operating schedule
modified to such extent as members
consider it necessary for the promotion
of the licensing objectives
and any mandatory conditions that must
be included
or two to exclude from the scope of the
license
any of the licensable activities to
which the application relates
three to reject the application or
four subjects to paragraphs one to three
of the licensing
acts 2003 hearings regulations 2005.
to adjourn the hearing to a specified
date or to arrange a hearing to be held
on
specified additional dates where members
consider
this necessary for the consideration of
any representations or notice made
by a party and that is the summary of
the report
thank you thank you mr greener and
before i
open up the floor to other uh attendees
speak to uh to ask mr greener questions
councilman first and councillor merrick
do you have any questions you wish to
ask
uh yes please chairman
sorry go ahead beg your pardon just go
ahead
thank you chairman steve couple of
questions please
um can you tell me um uh does this micro
pub
have to provide a smoking area
uh there is under separate legislation
that any premises
should automatically uh consider a
smoking area
um under the smoking regulations
so uh they should consider a suitable
location
um for people to go out to smoke yes but
not
necessarily considered under the
licensing act
okay so it basically it's a yes if if
for it yeah thank you um another
question um
do you know what the definition is of a
micropub
because i can't see in here that it says
how many people or capacity
in relation to capacity that is actually
governed by
the fire service and the fire regulatory
reform
act um it's not something that is
specifically mentioned under the
licensing act it's something that the
fire service actually pick up under
their own legislation
um so that's why it doesn't talk
necessarily around capacities
in relation to um a formal description
of a micro pub
um i will ask mr steve pegg to actually
mention that during his uh
um presentation around uh the micro pub
itself
um my understanding is that is a
small pub that sells craft wines and
beers
um and is very specialist
in that sort of area hence the word
micro
um and just one last um question please
um the report from the environmental
health
um hopefully i haven't missed it but i
can't see that there's any restrictions
around
delivery times
there is around things like empty in the
green glass the glass bottles that sort
of thing but i can't see anything around
deliveries
now the only condition that they've
agreed um on
the documentation i have is condition h
that says bottles glass bins shall not
be emptied
between the hours of 8 p.m and 10 a.m
monday to friday and not between the
hours of 8 00 p.m and 11 a.m
on saturday sundays and bank holidays i
can't see anything that talks around
delivery times no okay thank you
thank you councilman first and
councilman merrick any questions you'd
like to ask stephen
um yes german thank you just one
question
uh mr greener i'm a bit puzzled by the
reference to
or the description of the premises as a
micro pub
would i be writing my understanding that
that that is not relevant
in the terms of this application
no it is just we need to look at it
under the licensing act
officially it's a premises that is
selling alcohol and should
just be based on that obviously as i've
already mentioned
um mr peg will obviously be asked to go
into more detail around the application
and what is the actual business plan of
the actual venue
but for yourselves it's just to consider
whether you
are happy to approve the sale of alcohol
on the premises
so if if i may pursue that further
if if we gra if we were to grant the
license today
would i be writing thinking that that
does not restrict the use of the
premises
for licensing purposes to a micropub
now once a license has been granted then
that license can be transferred for a
number of different reasons
so for example if at a later stage that
premises wanted to become a restaurant
then effectively it could use the same
license
thank you thank you councilman
um mr green i've got a question for you
um forgive me i haven't seen this within
the report
um is there anywhere included within the
conditions and from a licensing
perspective
around the use of door staff and cctv
i'm just going to find my section in
relation to
agreed conditions with the police
normally it is the police application
sort of representation and conditions
that normally address
the use of door staff and cctv
just quickly finding that now for you
hi steve i could probably help you there
stephen
after long conversations with the
licensing officer
the police yes there are conditions for
cctv
and there also is a provision for for
door staff where it's necessary
okay thank you mr peg i'd like to expand
on that more than when i when you have
your chance to speak
mr green are you happy with that
response on your behalf uh
there is a little bit more that i can
actually refer you to within the actual
um conditions of the police proposed
conditions um
condition one is relating to where sia
licensed door star supervisors
are used at the premises a record should
be maintained
it also goes on to around
condition two talks around zero
tolerance policies
in relation to searching practices
scrutiny um
there doesn't look at the agree
conditions there is no
set uh request in there around cctv
itself okay that answers that question
thank you
and any other uh person who's uh here
this morning if you'd like to ask
mr green or any questions could you i
please ask you to raise your blue hand
by going to the participants section at
the bottom of the screen and clicking on
the raised hand icon and then i'll ask
you to speak in turn if anybody wishes
to ask mr greene or any questions
okay i can't see anybody indicating at
the moment
so i'm going to assume that uh nobody
wishes to
ask any questions thank you mr greeno
thanks very much so
um moving on then the applicant mr peg
is the opportunity now sir to um
give your uh submissions in regards to
this um
application this morning okay
lovely thank you as you know my name is
stephen pegg
um not to give my age away but i am
booked in for my first kobe jab on
thursday
give you an idea um i spent many many
years
my career working in the city of london
um
and then around about seven years ago uh
the concept of a micro pub
came across i came across the concept
um which really interested me the whole
thing about real ales
and the whole camera and their quest to
to to boost the sales of real i really
did interest me
and there are so many different real
ales it's incredible
so i did some research and looked into
the whole concept of a micro pub
which might help to answer one of the
questions actually it's not so much
about the size of the premises it's more
about the micro pub ethos
the i think that the term micro was
coined from some of the very early
microphones
the first one was in home bay uh there's
actually a butcher's before it became
a pub but it's more around
the atmosphere and ethos
of a drinking establishment which i
think that one of the best ways to
describe it would be an
an adult drinking establishment where
people would rather be able to hear
their own voices
and have a conversation uh rather than
thumping music or a sports bar which
many pubs are unfortunately nowadays
um there's a place for these what i
understand in
in the uh public place but the whole
micropub ethos
is more focused around probably catches
a group of people doing the crossword in
the pub rather than
hearing anybody say a crossword is one
of the best ways to describe this
and take away policies just a good as
also mentioned
it's more around real ale so we actually
would
we do currently in our other
establishment i'll talk about in a
second
we would do a takeaway really one of
these
which is a uh they call it a growler or
a
a small um a keg that's their takeaway
policy really
um so after my research i love the idea
it's the sort of place where i thought i
would like to be uh to enjoy a drink and
a friendly chat with friends
from family so we opened one green
bottle at battlesbridge antique center
and that was five years ago pretty much
to the date five years ago
where we've enjoyed a very good success
and and we've often been been noted how
we've brought the community together
which is the other part of the
micropublic ethos it's very very much a
community driven
establishment
so after that success for five years
which i've um
run with my wife as well uh anderson and
staff that we train
um we thought this is a good time to
look at expanding to two green bottles
to extend that same ethos to a another
establishment
so we've managed to find the premises at
16 golden cross
which i believe would be suitable uh it
has good public
transport with two bus routes one mile
away from watchful station
local taxi firm andrews i've lived in
this area for
all my life basically in hockley raleigh
and i now live only eight minute drive
away in south end
near prairie park
regarding to 16 golden cross the
smoking although i don't believe it's an
actual legal requirement
i actually would like to have we offered
the smoking area to the rear of the
premises
to avoid people standing in the on the
pavement in front which i don't believe
he's very sightly um not that it matters
but being the next smoker
i'd rather not have people in sight as
people are walking past the premises
i think that's very important just to
realize at this time as well
um the community spirit type of thing
especially at the moment we covered
to allow people to have a a place where
they can relax and enjoy
company is is very important i believe
it will be even more important as the
months go by
to allow that and although yes i
understand that within a mile each way
there will be other drinking
establishments
i still believe that there is a a call
with the number of
residents around that area
where they would like to be able to have
the opportunity to enjoy
a friendly quiet place to enjoy a drink
regarding live music yes we would intend
to have live music however
um our own submission as of a condition
was the fact that we we do value our
residents privacy
and well-being at heart as we are a
community driven
uh establishment but we would have a
restriction on that as well
imposed by ourselves of only a friday
saturday or sunday from 12
midday to 8 p.m and that would be
non-amplified live music as well
so it's more along the lines of some
background music
maybe an acoustic guitar that sort of
thing so we wouldn't wish to impose
loud music or noise on any surrounding
residence that isn't what
the whole idea of our establishment it
is about
it really is more about people maybe
having a game of backgammon or shove
hate me
or just having the general chat
basically and enjoying
a vast variety of different real ales
and in the last five years we have
bought some battles bridge
in a region of 500 or so different real
ales
that we source many from local breweries
george's brewery wakering uh keppel's
brewery
uh stanbridge we use maldon brewery
mighty oak
and i think this list can go on um
but with with that being said we do it
also sell other wines for example um
for other people to enjoy and everybody
likes a beer obviously
and of course soft drinks as well as
well along with tea and coffee
and what i call a bog standard ham or
cheese roll
very basic i would probably call it go a
bit old-fashioned even
to the campaign for real ale
was a great cause i would liken this
i've had many discussions with the denji
uh camera association it's
the great name but it's a campaign for
real atmosphere now
i think the people may crave for and
that's been proven in our
one green bottle our proven track record
um
we attract the the type of um
clientele that i want to attract
and which is an adult drinking community
i'm very very sensible as well
we have a zero drug policy that i've
discussed in great depths
with the police um and have
written procedures in place and the
training program
ready for staff and as well as a crowd
management policy as well
not that i envisaged there being large
crowds to contend with
however having our communities
well-being at heart
i'd always wish to make sure that they
were comfortable in knowing that we are
running um a professional
establishment
i think if i could open it up um deliver
delivery times
that wasn't actually discussed however
i'd be very very willing to discuss
a restriction on delivery times that
would make perfect sense to me as well
i wouldn't expect uh to have a delivery
an unsociable time at all it's not
something that i would wish
uh i think that when we first when i
first looked at my business plan
for one green bottle i wished it to be
an establishment that perhaps maybe
a single person could walk into and feel
comfortable
straight away so the the decor and the
environment is a
welcoming environment and i wish that to
be the same in two green bottles our
ethos remains consistent
uh that that's the same
i think as for my buyer that's my case
sir
mr wilkinson lovely thank you mr peg um
if you want my just muting
meeting yourself just uh until you ask
questions if you wouldn't mind
um okay thank you very much so let me
reset my time
so councilman ferguson and councillor
merrick
um any questions you'd like to ask first
of all before i do please
councilman mcpherson um uh thank you
chairman um
um just a couple um to you please mr peg
um you mentioned um um several times how
important it is to keep the efforts
of sort of chat um you mentioned things
like chef penny
um that sort of environment so could you
explain
why you would um have live music
i'm thinking of the possibility of
preventing any public sort of nuisance
around
noise yes certainly
um i'm not sure whether you've been to
many places where you've had live music
but by certainly the top
sort of folk music type thing that i'll
be a big fan of and and that's the
extent that i would ever want that to go
so
an acoustic guitar non-amplified would
be
that sort of thing would be the extent
of any live music and
it's really for uh background enjoyment
rather than to attract people to come
there as a gig
type thing because that just wouldn't be
the case at all
it's to get give somebody the chance to
maybe just play
some one or two people maximum to play
an instrument
just in the inner corner just to be some
quiet background music
it's certainly not any any more than
that
um and obviously um
you're going to have dorman on the door
if we if it's a special of the long
discussion
with the police officer around this
and if if it
be necessary it's a special evening and
this would be
a very much special evening if at all
uh where we expected there to be more
than
usual uh number of people attended and
then
yes then we would imply the correct uh
door staff to
to police that force as well with all of
you
empowered with all of the necessary um
enforcement that they'd need as well
that we would have as the licence holes
as well
i i don't envision that being a problem
i don't intend to have
any real special evenings in there uh
possibly with the exception of new
year's eve but even then
that would be debatable whether it would
even do that but
our special evening will be probably
from from six
till nine and it might be a cheese and
real tasting and wine tasting session
uh mr peg i'm not referring to any
special evening
yeah um what i'm talking about nobody in
your premises will be allowed to take
their drink outside and stand on the
pavement
so i will be policing that without a
doorman
our staff police that as we do now as we
would also police
serving anybody under age or you know
it we're very experienced in this our
existing establishment and although it
being an antique center i'm not sure if
he's familiar with it but we have had
some busier times there
and our staff are are very experienced
at
um making sure people do adhere to our
rules as well
because at the end of the day if if
rules are broken then
they lose their establishment that they
they'd like to attend so
people are very very um i'll say happy
to
to adhere to that if they're not happy
then unfortunately they won't be served
and i'm absolutely clear about that as
well
um i'd rather not serve somebody than
risk the chance of upsetting anybody and
and that's just the way it is and that
ethos carries on all the way through
to our staff as well that are regularly
regularly
updated about that as well
okay um and this is um
rather different to your other premises
and the fact that this is in the middle
of a
residential area so the other question
will be around
policing the smoking area because as you
say
it's going to be an adult only
establishment
with adults come certain conversations
etc
and we do have a lot of families in the
vicinity
good that's that's true i mean uh we say
it's in the middle of an antique center
there's also
it's very family orientated there as
well
um on a busy saturday or sunday there's
families walking past so we do have an
outside area there as well
so that's just that's something that i i
don't
um i don't condone the use of bad
language
at all i particularly wanted to keep
smokers to the rear of the building
rather than being in the front
to maybe bother more residents or other
shoppers as well
so that would be there no drinks will be
taken outside
either and while they're smoking they
smoke and come back in
they'll be sufficient ashtrays made
available for them to remove their or to
extinguish their cigarettes but most of
the point as well think that we will
have
strategic place cctv that will include
the realtor property the front of the
property and any other
areas inside we then fit and this will
be
not only would the staff have clear line
of sight to many places in there
they'll also have access to the cctv
monitors
that they can see behind the bar as well
yeah um you are aware the rear of your
property has residential
um properties as well yeah
yes yeah thank you chairman
thank you councilman first and
councillor merrick
thank you chairman no i have no
additional questions thank you very much
mr peg i've got several questions for if
i may yeah
okay um do you know
the the car park out the rear do you
know the status of the land is it
publicly owned or privately owned
i believe that's privately owned by the
uh by the
owners of of golden cross shopping
parade
have you spoken to about the use of it
yes you have yeah i i hope yes i have
and they they're happy with that consent
okay okay
yes yes okay um
sorry if you don't mind of course as
steven mentioned about
the smoking area i don't believe it's an
absolute have to do
but i really wish to do that to
to remove people from the pavement in
the front of the premises
which at the end of the day is a public
right of way i can't stop people walking
along there
i totally i totally understand where
you're coming from mr peg and i would
agree with that sentiment i
i want to make sure that um if we are
minded to grant any permissions today
the council's not complicit
in you conducting activities on private
land that you're not able to oh no
no no okay that's parallel sorry okay
um so uh
why your your premises
in battles bridge and i think councilman
ferguson did talk about this quite
rightly
um is in a very very different
geographical um
situation to the one that we're
discussing today
um there's no or very very very little
residential area
of premises around that one bottle yeah
i noticed that your timings for the one
green bottle
are uh well this application is for
longer hours
and yet it's in a residential area can
you explain why that is
but yeah certainly um for
you quite right one green buffalo it's
not as residential
so more people and the public transport
isn't as good or there is a train
there's a train line there but it's it's
uh it's not as
reliable and it's not very often so more
people would probably drive to
one green bottle um and it's it's busier
when we have
the uh the rest of the antique center
open
so there's the footfall is when the
antique centres open
okay so you're thinking your timings are
around football then
um not necessarily mainly around that
yes around
the footfall for one green button where
and to be honest with you our even if
our license
uh for example is till 11 pm
um quite often we are shut by 8 p.m
you know we we we don't
we deserve the right to close early as
well so we wouldn't
necessarily be open until late on a a
monday night for example if there's just
not worth it no that's what i i don't
understand
the reason i ask the question is because
i don't understand why when you're
proposing to put a license premises
underneath residential flats where young
children live you're
going to be doing longer hours than you
do in a rural setting that's the point i
don't
seem to quite understand but you've
explained that because i think i've got
this right you're saying basically
because of the footfall predominantly
yeah basically yeah i i believe that
there'd probably be a more reasonable
amount of
local people to to golden cross that may
enjoy
you know a drink site slightly later
than than at bethlehem's bridge
okay well that brings me nicely on to
the next point then um there is
um we sort of regard us with the spirit
should we say within the licensing
objectives the licensing legislation is
that we there is an expectation really
that
licensing and actual actual fact it's um
any
responsible license holder should do
this is that a licensee will engage
with the community in which he's
situating himself with engage with the
local residents
could you explain to the panel what
engagement you have done
with the local residents for where
you're proposing to put this
premises i okay yeah i
i was actively going to uh engage with
the local residents
however i was actually put off from
doing that
um when i it was brought to my attention
that
the caring for rochford facebook
community group
was showing some uh some
upset comments on there at first
around this and i thought this is
probably better not to engage the
community to possibly
start conversations with myself
around where our proposals were that may
have
actually clouded the water and muddied
the water slightly when it came to our
application so since then i've spoken to
other people that are on this
caring for rockford group and the
support was growing
immensely for our establishment to go
ahead
and i believe they're asked to take the
post down because
they weren't really understanding uh or
didn't like the fact that the support
was growing
in normally i i would have engaged the
residents
normally i would have done but in this
instance when as soon as i heard that
that was happening
i thought it best not to because i may
seem to be interfering rather than than
helping
okay but i note that you don't have
anybody supporting you with you today
in your application you're saying you've
got
additional support now but there's
nobody here supporting you
to be fair i wasn't actually told i
could bring i i
i asked the question if i could bring
somebody to help represent
myself but at no point would i
have thought about a community member to
back up my application
like that wasn't something that was
suggested to me i would have thought
about doing so apologies
because it's your application but at the
end of the day i'm sure
because i know stephen green very well
he would have explained everything
councilman first and he wished to answer
sorry um thank you chairman um
yeah just checking i wasn't on you um
i'm going to declare an interest
um um mr pegs just raised um
that this was um brought up on caring
about rochford
i'm one of the admins on the group i
will state here
i know not of this post nor would i ever
um nor did i approve it or comment on it
or have heard of it before this moment
okay
thank you chairman thank you councilman
and um sonia can we
ensure that's recorded as a as an
interest
that's quite good
mr peg one second sonia sorry could i
just confirm that you heard what council
refers to
yes of course sir chairman thank you
very much mr peg thank you
sorry just a bit i'm not a member of the
caring for rochford facebook group so
i i was only repeating what i heard but
just to confirm
is the council saying that there's
actually no comments
around this application mr peg it's not
your position to
to question counselor first what she is
commenting on she's made a
um a comment in relation to something
you said so you're saying you've seen it
she's declaring an interest and she has
to do legally
as a member of this council somebody
mentioned it to me i haven't seen it
myself so that's fine that's fine that's
fine thank you
all right okay okay moving on then
do you know what the building's actually
made from the construction of the
building
you aware of that at all i'm actually
not aware of that
i'm not aware of that no i mean the uh
the the landlord the landlord i
would hope that is make sure that the
building is
of the correct construction yeah i think
about the building falling down so much
as the
the the noise um because
um i think the noise resonating up
through the walls
um we have to take into account as one
of the licensing objectives nuisance
um and disturbance to the residents are
obviously upstairs and
also to the residents who are outside
and live around the building now
i'm aware that environmental health have
agreed some conditions around
soundproofing
the building with you and i i'm i'm not
too sure
um how effective that is
um and i'm very mindful that we don't
cause disturbance to those
those families who live upstairs some of
them who have young children
um and i'm sure that plays on your mind
as well so that's why i'm not interested
in in
if you've looked at what that building's
actually made from and can actually be
effectively soundproofed
well i haven't looked at what it's been
made from although
it is brick built i i understand it is
brick built
i mean this is obvious you can see that
from the extra outside than the walls
but
however i'm very very mindful of the
of the the residents above as well um
so there's apart from the soundproof
materials to be placed on the ceiling
to to help with that there's actually a
false
suspended ceiling that will also allow
an additional air gap
to reduce any noise and vibrations that
go through
that that i will be keeping i'm very
the the walls of brick built walls but
sorry what
sound proofing you proposing for the
walls because sam resonates at walls as
well
it it does it does i mean i'm happy to
look at
other materials to use on the walls i
mean i was intending to
kind of clad the walls with um with
probably wooden paneling
that we can put some sound proofing
behind as well which would would assist
okay i'm very mindful i'm taking up a
lot of time here so i'm going to be very
very quick and move on
uh two final questions one is regarding
cctv i note that mr green is the only
one that's not a requirement at the
moment
um you've mentioned that you are going
to put cctv in yeah
um but only part coverage are you going
to have the whole
thing inside covered or not yeah yes
that would we have
yeah we
cctv will be inside and outside the
premises
and that's not just for um
basically i'd i would very insist
insist that we have a vision of the
whole
surrounding inside and outside of the
establishment
okay that's fine one final question
before i move to the others to be able
to speak to you
um obviously today we need to consider
not just the main license application
but also a pavement license application
i know from the reports that have been
shared with us essex police
are still against this even with the
reduced number of tables could you
explain to us why you're still
proposing to move forward with this even
though essex police are against it
i don't believe ethics police are
against it last time i spoke to
the last the officer um
there was a condition put it would be
only till 8 p.m in the evening and it's
four chairs only
which was the revised application i
believe stephen had
and the last time i spoke to keeley's
they weren't opposed to it at all
well i've seen emails dated um where are
we so i broke this down
there's an email date to the 5th of
february and then the further one dated
the
10th i think oh dated the 10th of
february um
the first one is from key the second one
is
i haven't written down who the second
one's from but basically the second one
reinstates the concerns around prime
disorder
for any outdoor seating
okay i mean um
if i've got that wrong i don't want to
mislead the other panel members but
that's the way i
i read it though you are correct in
relation to
the alcohol license conditions have been
agreed
um via the police licensing officer that
oversees castle point and richard
the application in relation to the
seating area was conducted by six police
headquarters
and they have actually um the
the actual representations that they
made is on
page 5.30 of um sorry
5.28 of the
uh report in relation to pavement
permissions so
it was two different departments that
looked at this application yeah
so my understanding is that they are
still against any
outstall seating so you may not be aware
of that and i accept that
i'm concerned that you're still trying
to request something that the police
as a statutory authority are not not in
support of
okay i mean which is which is fair
enough and i obviously wouldn't want to
go
uh against any police recommendations
like that not without good reason so
i mean every other condition i've agreed
with the police every other one and my
procedures policies and procedures all
agreed with the police so they're happy
with everything else
um to grant the license but if they're
still concerned about a pavement license
and
although i think that for people sitting
outside probably wouldn't
actually cause any uh any issues at
all but if they are still opposed to it
then of course i i
i don't i withdraw my
oh i withdraw because i i don't want to
do anything against the police
well you need to make that clear mr peg
as to whether you officially would join
the application or not
because we can't be left in limbo okay
well if the application is already in
progress and it's to be discussed by the
the committee here then we'll leave it
in place because okay
although i don't wish to go against the
police as the ball is already rolling as
you mentioned
and i don't believe that four chairs
outside will cause any
additional uh distress or harm to
anybody we'll leave it in for discussion
mr erwin i can see you wish to speak
sorry charles just going to say i think
we're kind of veering into the second
application in terms of the pavement
license i think you wanted to keep them
separate is that
correct well we need to discuss them
both because we can go into deliberation
to talk about the both at the same time
i think the idea was that you're going
to start from scratch um with the
licensing officer
if you still want to do it that way
chair okay that's
okay that's not the maybe i
misunderstood that when we're discussing
earlier on chris um i do apologize it's
not uh
that's what i understood you're saying
sonia i'm just going to say chairman
they are separate reports separate items
on the agenda so we
need to deal with the with ice and fire
that's fine that's absolutely fine i do
apologize we can discuss that afterwards
then okay
right i'm not going to take up any more
time um so
other members present and um mr martin
himself
obviously if you wish to ask any
questions of mr peg can you please
click on the residence box at the bottom
the participant's box of the boston
mother and raise your blue hand
if you wish to ask any questions
if you can't do that please say so to
put your hand in the air i can see you
uh no no questions to be asked thank you
all right
uh councillor gooding
thank you chairman um i'm a little bit
concerned where the
the microbrewery is concerned
with speaking can you allow the the
member to ask a question please
subscribe
where um the applicant has spoken about
the customers will be speaking and maybe
doing a crossword
i cannot see how this fits in with live
music
and the acoustic guitars that um are two
different
very different venues in my view
is there a question you wish to ask mr
peg counselor billy
yes just you know yep i'm sorry who's
gonna answer that
okay yeah i i can't understand when i
said crossword it's just like a
um an example that you may see someone
doing a crossword
rather than hear them uttering a
crossword at all
um so that the idea of just live
background music
is for people's enjoyment while they
still talk i mean our
background music is played everywhere
you go
in shops and things you can still manage
to talk to people
and as there's music in many pubs
already
if not live remember this is not
amplified music
and it's a restriction i've put on on
myself as well
because i still want people to be able
to enjoy a conversation
in our establishment well perhaps
there's somebody playing some live music
now of course people may
sit there and enjoy that music as well
and choose to listen to it rather than
talk
but at no point would that music be loud
enough to overpower
anyone else's enjoyment of conversation
okay we are like the pub and it's not a
brewery by the way it's a micro pub just
for
clarity right
okay so we now have three um
visiting uh two visiting members and a
member of the public so i'm assuming all
three of you wish to speak
um so what i'm going to do is
uh you you've got 15 minutes between the
three of you
so if i may i will time each of you to
five minutes
um to hopefully give you all a fair time
and obviously if you only take up two
minutes to start then
we'll add that on at the end and mr
martin
can i start with you please sir
yes certainly um i'm going to raise
objections
under the free headings i'll start with
crime
this micropuff could become a target for
the practice of underage drinking as
this area is a congregating point
for school children after school and
bearing in mind a few 17 year old six
farmers look 25
they will pass the visual id check
that's point one
point two the rear of the property is a
known area for drug dealing and this has
been reported to the police in the past
so this pub could attract some unwelcome
clients
number three the likelihood is that
there will become an increase in public
or
order offences by means of urinating in
public
listerine and abusive language
especially when it comes to closing time
which would impact on the local
residents
although the area served by the number
seven and eight bus routes
people may choose to use a private
vehicle to access the premises
this in some cases may make the
temptation to drive
whilst over the legal limit an option
people who do use a car to visit will
find there is limited parking
and will probably choose to park on the
pavement causing damage to the already
fragile kerbstones
and further limiting pedestrian access
under public safety congregating outside
the front in guerrero is likely to block
the safe passageway for pedestrians
the allocation of a one meter for
smoking area to the rear
will lead to the residents and their
children above being subjected to
secondhand smoke
as the balcony is in effect to their
garden
the smokers below could be vulnerable to
falling objects from above as there is
no barrier
to prevent this from happening and
children will be playing with stuff
in their garden the people choosing to
make
use of the smoking area to the rear of
the premises will be unlikely to stay
within the allocated one meter
and may tend to walk around an area
which is a designated car park
for the shops and residents of the flats
with traffic coming in and out
this will increase the chance of an
accident involving a vehicle
the door to the rear of the property is
a fire exit and has to be kept clear
given that the smoking area is going to
be located outside this store
people congregating may cause an
obstruction to this
now under public nuisance the most
obvious nuisance will be an increase of
noise for the residents
the opening times i propose to go on
beyond midnight
on sundays so residents will be subject
to doors slamming there'll be extra
traffic
and an increase in the loudness of
people leaving
who have taken alcohol
music will be heard with the opening and
closing of the door
the pavement license application which i
believe i'm still allowed to comment on
under public nuisance the public license
application has been refused twice by
six police
and other interested parties and for
good reason
and that is that the frontage cannot
accommodate any obstruction due to its
size
surely all these respected groups cannot
have got it wrong
any altercation to this any alteration
to this decision
will result in pedestrians disabled and
people with children
to navigate past those sitting and
drinking alcohol
which could be intimidating to those
with a nervous disposition
smokers will accept the placing of seats
on the pavement as an invitation to
smoke at the front
of the premises and with only one member
of staff in attendance
to propose no smoking policy by the
applicant will be impossible to police
the proposed measurement of the
furniture which we've seen
on the application will make it an ideal
weapon should a disagreement
escalate outside the staff may be
tempted when clearing up bottles and
other rubbish
to use the bins in the rear car part
which are specifically for the use of
residents in the flats
the company that collects and empties
these bins have refused to take them in
the past
if they contain trade waste so they're
my objections under the three headings
and i would like the option of giving up
something up
uh when that time comes please
and if you could mute yourself mr must
mr peg could give me to yourself as well
please sir
um that's the butcher if i may come to
you next uh as the ward councillor
son you're as host are you able to
unmute councillor butcher at all and
sister
unfortunately not i can only ask her to
unmute herself she might want to try
pressing the space bar if um
okay we appear to have lost it for the
time being and to save delay
councillor gooding can i come to you
next please
good morning all yes my name is julie
gooding um
as previously heard the the venue
is situated within a residential area
there are many families living above the
proposed micro pub
who have have raised their concerns
regarding the disturbance of noise from
the customers who frequent
who will frequent the venue which will
cause a public nuisance
i understand there are conditions for
surrendering i'm not hearing anything
mr wilkinson uh well
i am is anybody else not
are you all hearing counselor gooding
okay yep yeah i am mr martin you might
need to check your sound sir
cancer getting please carry on sorry i
understand there are conditions for
soundproofing to be installed
this council has learned from previous
experience of a micro pub
that soundproofing whilst it may reduce
the noise it does not stop
the sound vibrating up the walls and
beams therefore residents with young
children
are concerned this presents preventative
measure
will not be as effective and causing a
public nuisance
i also note that there was a previous
planning application for this refusal
previously for exactly the same reason
of a noise
disturbance which would be a public
nuisance
also such venue attracting people to
gather
outside the premises which would cause
littering of cigarette butt
and this would be crime and prevention
disorder
by the littering people living above the
venue
have a solid floor with the false
ceiling inside the micro
pub the ceiling i am advised needs to be
accessible for the utilities
therefore i question the ability to
contain the noise within the venue
with this setup as previously
soundproofing has not worked effectively
again resulting in public nuisance
having visited the area further concerns
were raised regarding the rear of the
micro pub
where it is proposed to be a smoking
area
there is a very limited area adjacent to
the
privately owned car park i noted
cars parked as near as approximately
a meter away from the property which in
my understanding this area has served as
a pedestrian footwear
for those to avoid walking through the
where cars are parked which raises
public safety concerns
also if the customers are gathering
outside to smoke
this could cause an obstruction for the
pedestrians
including wheelchair users and partially
sighted pedestrians
and who also want to access the walkway
furthermore people gathering outside
will create noise which in turn will be
a public nuisance for residents with
children living above the venue
the children living directly above the
proposed smoking area
currently enjoy their only outdoor space
to play
the noise generated from customers under
the influence of alcohol
would not be a suitable environment for
children to observe
from their balcony along with the impact
of the smoke
rising which could cause harm so that
would be a public safety concern
cars parked adjacent to the rear of the
premises
are also at risk from damage as there is
no
barrier to separate the smoking area
from the car park
so this could cause crime and disorder
my main concern is the collecting of
people congregating outside the venue
on the footpath any permanent street
furniture
on the footwear would reduce access for
the pedestrians and those with mobility
impaired
or visually impaired people as set out
in section 3.1 of the
inclusive mobility and so that again
that's public safety
those are my concerns thank you
thank you councillor gooding uh
councillor butcher welcome back
um yes you're able to all right we can
hear you now that's good
before you speak mr martin um can you
hear everything that's being said now
i assume so by the fact you're answering
me yes i um
i lost uh the ability to hear what uh
councillor gooding was saying
but that's fine i'm back with you i
logged out and come back in again
okay lovely thank you very much uh
councillor butcher
yes thank you i'm sorry about that i've
had trouble with zoom this morning this
is first time i've been able to see you
all
um i haven't heard what everybody has
said
so i i would assume i'm probably
repeating a lot of what has already been
said
but i am the uh local award counsellor
uh there was a previous refusal in
september 2008
um and the reason for that was it was
cited close to existing dwellings
detrimental
amenities which neighbouring residents
could otherwise enjoy by virtue of
increase
in noise smells nuisance and disturbance
with visitors to the site particularly
late evening
street parking and the noise of cars
leaving
i feel that these are still the same
reasons to refuse this
this is a residential area with
bungalows housing a lot of older people
who are mainly living away from a main
town to avoid the noise and disturbance
that occurs there
the flats above these shops
house lots of families with children
and probably has already been said the
balcony
is the children's play area
the shops are convenience shops with
flats above
it's not a town centre shopping center
i believe this application will have a
detrimental effect on local residents
the noise that this will bring the
application is for an entertainment and
socializing venue
brings with it visitors who will be
socializing talking together talking's
not
quite listening to music
and smoking outside i'm sure the smoking
has been
mentioned the one meter at the back
is actually across a pathway around the
um
shops so this will be blocked for people
to
to walk around um on that pathway
causing them to walk where the cars are
parked
this i think is a risk it's a it's a
risk
to the people living above in those
flats with the smoke
lack of sleep for these children
children need their sleep
has also been mentioned before school
hours and after school hours a lot of
young children
congregate there this sometimes calls a
bit of a nuisance
but they also will be at risk now there
will be additional risks for them
the structure of the building is formed
on a concrete foundation
slabs between the properties as solid
concrete with no sound barriers
noise and vibrations carry
i have spoken to one of the residents
who says that when there's work being
carried out
five doors away they can hear this
now i know um the applicant said he
hadn't
um spoken to residents
i actually have had sight of a
petition which i understand cannot be
used but it's got 36 names on it
but i've spoken to many many many more
people in this area
residents of the flats the houses at the
side
bungalows and i have to say i haven't
found
one person who supports this application
not one
sitting outside on the table yes four
chairs
people sitting there drinking can't stop
them smoking
it's a public area it will block the
pavement it's not very wide
in recent months when there have been
four people
queuing at the bakery there i've noticed
people with
prams wheelchairs having to go into the
road
to get past there this is a nuisance
it's a public nuisance and public safety
and i think there's going to be harm to
children and
people living in that residential area
crime and disorder you get
alcohol you get people drinking too much
sometimes
that can lead to crime and disorder
i really don't think that this is the
right
venue for this type of application
and i strongly oppose it
on behalf of my residents and as i say
there has been a many many residents
who have spoken to me about this thank
you
thank you council butcher um councilman
first and councilor merrick
would either of you to like to ask any
questions of the
three members who have just spoken
at all
no thank you jim
you're shaking your head counseling at
first and i see that's a no shaking my
head and not being able to turn the mute
off uh no thank you very much
chairman thank you okay right so
um now i would like to ask mr
peg if i may to uh summarize your
application
and present your final submissions if
you wish to
check sorry you want to just check if um
any of the other parties had any
questions for um
the interested parties such as the
applicant and mr greener
that's a very good point thank you very
much that's why you're here isn't it
it's a reminder keep me on track
thank you um mr greener uh first of all
do you have anything you wish to ask
the three people have just spoken um no
but what i will do
is while we've had this call i've had a
couple of emails in relation to
um people that i work with within the
council that have actually answered some
of
the questions that might be useful to
you um one's in relation to
environmental health and in relation to
general deliveries
um and they say they would actually
consider that under the pending
planning application that is currently
being submitted it wouldn't have been
something that they would have
automatically
looked at under the licensing act also
as well
from a planning aspect in relation to
the extent of the use of the smoking
area
i've got the email to say that in their
professional opinion um they would need
planning consent because it will be a
change of use of the part of the car
park
so again that would have to be
considered unpart of the planning
application
but both of those emails i've had within
the last couple of minutes that i
thought that
it would be um prudent for the the
members to hear it
but as far as i'm concerned i have no
questions in relation to
the the residents or those making
representation
thank you mr greener mr peg is anything
you'd like to ask any of the three
people have just spoken to
the two councillors and mr martin
you need to unmute yourself sir
thank you no specific questions to ask
them but
i i'd like to make a few comments on
what on what was said if that's possible
dive time for that
well you you the next stage actually is
for you to make your closing submission
so if you'd like to do that yes that
rolls nicely into it yeah if that's a
tile as well yeah okay
absolutely feel free you've got a couple
of minutes sir brilliant
okay so um i actually welcome
everybody's
comments as well because as i said we
are very very much community driven
if if our community doesn't support it
in general with lots of people and
there's a
rocha is a big area i think it's around
about 85 to 90 000 residents in the
rockford area alone
um so
running through very quickly just some
points that were raised uh
the the the co-op sells alcohol ready
we wouldn't be a first and as i
mentioned our takeaway
policy although we would have bottles to
sell will probably be more expensive
and plus the better takeaways for relay
will be something like this
probably not something that that 17 year
old's gonna
purchase and certainly wouldn't uh
because we challenged 25 as well
as part of our policy with proof of age
um the drug dealing thing this could
concerns me
um quite rightly and any anti-social
behavior
however i believe that the strategically
placed cctv
and and adult community uh
clients that we'll attract will actually
assist in
reducing any anti-social behaviour
um
for people at the front of the of the of
the property
to to drink wouldn't be smoking because
if they
if they decide to smoke then they won't
be serving alcohol so they won't be
enjoying that either so
our rules are our rules it's part of our
licensed premises so
they have to abide by our rules and
the reason we didn't want to introduce a
smoking area
was to actually stop people smoking on a
public footpath in front
um i said that we'd rather have
introduced that as we said
and someone else mentioned you can't
stop people
smoking in public areas i'd like to
restrict that by way of a
a rule that we could have to reduce any
nuisance caused by that
um if it's a public right of way well
signs will be
displayed saying that the public right
of way must be
uh respected and that anybody wishing to
use that is given that
access as well as keeping that fire door
exit clear at all times which will be a
a must and clearly
uh sign posted as well the music was
mentioned again
this this again i can't stress enough
this is background music
only so even with the doors open this
wouldn't be something that would annoy
anybody
any more than someone driving past with
a car window open
with maybe some distasteful music
flaring out which is more likely to
happen than
being disturbed by our spanish guitarist
in the corner possibly
the waste collection again that was
mentioned by steve i will look into
other options for that as well
because uh again one of the conditions
was the noise of bottles being disposed
of
wouldn't be between certain hours that i
wouldn't wish to disturb anybody
or cause any issues with waste disposal
so i'd look into other options as well
with the
with the owner as well as the whole of
golden cross
um so we have many conditions in place
for the noise reduction and
i'd be very happy to look into the type
of cladding that we could use on the
walls
to assist in that as well and there is a
suspended ceiling which would help the
noise reduction
and vibration to go through the roof
with additional sound briefing
still allowing access to the amenities
of coals that we need to
as i said i'm happy to look into
anything else i could do to help with
the the walls and noise would be reduced
um okay next thing
uh if in 2008 there may have been a
uh an application that was that wasn't
granted but
as 13 years ago and the whole micropub
ethos has grown and become a lot more
known uh in the last 13 years
i think that the the whole thing about
the
the type of uh clientele
is very very much more known now in the
micropub world and ethos
sorry one more minute if i may okay yep
uh you've been mentioned that a lot of
people have objected i think if the
similar thing have gone out you've also
found that
a lot of people would support it i know
i didn't bring along anybody
to to back that up but i still believe
there are uh
crime and disorder again i believe that
with an adult
attracted establishment with strategic
place cctv
and adults around even leaving the
premises would actually
uh assist in reducing any anti-social
behavior
especially if this is taking place when
the rest of the golden cross shops in
that area
are closed i think that the children are
offenders would be less inclined to
offend if they knew that there was
adults around there
oh last thing just uh like to thank
everybody for your time
um and that's my case thank you thank
you mr peg um
councilman first and captain america is
anything you'd like to ask mr pegg
before we close the meeting we won't be
closing just yet but there's anything
else you'd like to ask mr peg
no no no thank you chairman okay right
i'm gonna give two minutes now to the
three
members of the public members and mr
martin
if you wish to you there's no compulsion
to and mr martin he said he'd like to
i'm gonna start with you mr martin
uh two minutes sir if you may um just to
finalize your case
yeah summing up some residents have
become very anxious
and stressful because of this
application to change the use
of this shop as this is a quite
residential area micropilot has never
been sought or needed by local residents
the fact that several local councillors
have raised objections
is indicative of the feeling of their
constituents
the area is furnished with many drinking
establishments
in fact there were so many that quite a
few have become unsustainable
and were forced to close for good the
flats above
for families some are young children and
having spoken
with some of them they are fearful that
the noise and public nuisance
will impact on their children's
well-being and finally this may
sound like a sledgehammer to crack a nut
but
article 14 protocol one of the human
rights acts
states that i had the right to a
peaceful life in my property
and i have and would like to retain it
thank you
now thank you mr martin let's just mute
yourself again please so councillor
butcher
if you'd like just have a couple of
minutes just to summarize if you may
look yes just to uh reiterate
um what mr martin has said
um this is certainly not the venue
for this type of establishment
this i will say again is a residential
area
away from the town with convenience
stores
the noise that this will cause will be
to the detriment
of all the local people it's all very
well saying
that outside the tables will not
create people smoking i'm sorry if
you've got four people sitting out there
and somebody comes along who knows
someone they can stand and talk and make
noise they don't care if they're not
going to be served because they're not
going in there
they're just conversing with their
friends
socializing is about talking and
enjoying yourself and having a laugh
this is not the place for that
this is not the place to have
people gathering people smoking we have
children living here
there are cars there could be accidental
damage
or deliberate damage to the cars people
leaving
slamming their doors when they're going
home
it really is not appropriate and i hear
what mr pig says about some people would
be in favor of it
certainly not any of the people that i
have spoken to
and i say this very very strongly
because people have been
almost crying to me about this
application
they feel very very strongly about it
and i
speak out for all of them thank you
thank you councillor butcher councillor
gooding couple minutes
yes i would just like to concur with the
previous two speakers
and the concerns raised by the residents
regarding
the the area for the table and chairs
and people gathering outside the venue
which will cause disturbance from their
noise
therefore a public nuisance to
the residents living in the area the
smoking outside the venue
which despite what mr pegg has said
will happen because i've witnessed it
myself people walking by they are able
to smoke outside
so the increase of people smoking around
the facility
will impact on the public health and
safety
of the residents living above the venue
and the littering will increase which is
obviously a crime and disorder act
and i i can't stress strongly enough
that the people that have spoken to me
have raised serious concerns because
this is not the place
in a residential area for a micro pub
thank you thank you very much
uh councillor gooding right okay now
i am aware that we've already touched on
this next
item um and mainly um
the fault lies with me i'll be quite
honest with you um but we need to
discuss
the pavement license as well um
and this shouldn't take long because i
know that we've touched on it and as a
result many of you have as well
uh mr greener um could i ask you first
sir if you could just
outline the position with regards to the
pavement license application please all
right check
let's um interject of course again
just to see if mr green had any some uh
closing remarks on
the previous i forgot you did remind me
and i forgot so i do apologize
mr green i'm sorry before you start on
this new application there anything you
want to say in regards to the last one
no again just by providing a little bit
of clarity i have actually forged on the
email to the solicitor already again
i've had another email from
environment health with a little bit of
guidance around soundproofing
if the members decide to grant the
license and
self-proof soundproofing is discussed
the recommendation both on an alcohol
license and planning
application would be for an acoustic
engineer to come and do
a independent assessment of the site um
that way that it's not sort of biased
towards
either parties so uh certainly that was
a recommendation
by environmental health but uh no
there's no closing statement
in relation to uh rocha district council
but i thought that might be helpful
very helpful thank you mr greene okay if
we can move on then uh just outline the
position for the lice the
pavement license please yes of course um
in relation to an application
for a payment permission this is for
a license to be granted for payment
permission under section 2 of the
business and planning act
2020. in june 2020 the government
announced
a relaxation to planning and licensing
laws
to help the hospitality industry to
recover from the corolla virus
locked down by removing short-term
obstacles
that would ordinarily get in their way
the legislation introduced a temporary
fast-track
process for a pavement license for the
placement of furniture such as tables
and chairs
on the pavement adjacent to the premises
which would enable them to maximize
their capacity
whilst adhering to social distancing
guidelines
originally an application was submitted
on behalf
of county al's limited the premises
for which it relates obviously we have
discussed already
the application for the grant of the
premises license was first submitted on
the 4th of february 2021
and requested for the use of 12 chairs
and three tables
a size of 50 square centimeters
and a copy of the application form is
appendix a
once the information has been submitted
to us we had 10
working days for the application to be
determined
and to consult on and determine the
application
considerations when looking at the
application
whether to grant the license we must
consider
the key sort of points public health and
safety
public amenities and accessibility
including the inclusion of section 3.1
of the inclusive mobility act
initially in accordance with section 3
of the business and planning
act the application was reviewed by
members of essex highways
essex police rocha district council
community safety team
the planning department and environment
health and obviously myself as well
the responsible followers of the group
determined that the applications
submitted
on the 4th of february failed to comply
with the national standards
in relation to no obstructions which
basically meant that there wasn't
the two meter space to accommodate all
the
the tables and chairs in the original
application
and the application was initially
refused on the 9th of february 2021
and the copy of the refusal letter is
attached as appendix b
on the 10th of february the applicant
asked for the group to reconsider an
application reducing the number of
tables and chairs
to two tables and four chairs
to actually be placed in the alcove bit
of
the premises again the application was
submitted
and reviewed by both essex police and
the planning department
made representations against the
application on the revised
plans essex highways assessed the
application and they also
raised concerns appendix c is a copy of
the representations that received
we also received two representations
from local residents
during the consultation period
in considering or reconsidering the
application
we felt that the that the business had
yet to be granted an alcohol license and
to operate as a licensed premises
and it should run as a micro pub for at
least six months
pending an alcohol license being granted
to demonstrate that the responsible
authorities and the residents
that the venue could be run safely
and the outside seating area would not
create additional noise or concerns
and on that basis the application was
refused
in support of the representations
going to point 13 of the report is
proposed that
the committee resolves the application
with one of the following to either
grant
the pavement permission license or
grant the payment permission license and
impose conditions or refuse the
application
that is the end of the report
thank you mr greener um councilman first
and counselor merrick are any questions
or clarification you wish to seek from
mr greener regarding that
i have no question thank you
mr peg i'll come to you in a second sir
councillor mcpherson
okay um anybody
uh mr mr peg i will give you an
opportunity to speak
uh in a second but does anybody else
just put your hand up don't worry with
the blue hands because
there's only what nine or ten of us does
anybody else wish to seek any
clarification
on any point that mr greener has just
raised
mr martin
yeah the frontage of the
property is angular but
there would be no possible way of having
two tables and four chairs mr mr martin
mr martin do you wish to seek
clarification as opposed to making a
point i'm going to give you an
opportunity to make your
case against if you wish to i just wish
to
to ascertain if you want to clarify
anything mr green has mentioned
no i beg your pardon no that's
absolutely fine that's a
councilman first and you're back with us
good are you okay
yeah sorry i hadn't gotten it um it had
time down and i couldn't get back in
that's that's absolutely fine
um is there anything you'd like to what
did you hear what mr greener said
yes i did um not a present i haven't got
any questions on this thank you
okay you didn't miss anything that mr
greene has said then
no i didn't thank you lovely thank you
um council butcher councillor gooding
anything you'd like to clarify with mr
greener
no okay
right mr peg um if you'd like to
summarize your application please for
the pavement license
yeah just very very very quickly um
the first of all the tables and chairs
would not be permanent fixtures anyway
they'd be removable at the end of the
day they'd be
uh kept inside the premises so that they
wouldn't be
kept outside uh
the second i think very important to to
mention that
when essex highways did their initial
report on this they actually had the
incorrect dimensions of the pavement
and stephen greener very kindly went
down and re-re-measured them
so i think that's very important to to
note that their information was
incorrect
at first um and thank you very much for
stephen for doing that
but apart from that um it would happen
for restrictions
to be placed upon this because i don't
wish this to be
uh cause any issues as far as smoking's
concerned if people are walking past
people can walk
in the right street anyway i think that
that isn't really a valid argument
people smoke in a public
place anyway and as it's as this would
form part of my licensed
area we can we can
stipulate it's a non-smoking seating
area so
apart from that um that i have nothing
else to add thank you
i'm muted thank you mr pegg councilman
fursten councillor merrick anything
you'd like to ask mr peg
i don't think so um thank you very much
chairman
okay councillor merrick thank you
chairman thank you very much
um i'm i know i've already touched on
this mr peg but i
i um still have concerns about the
um that there's obviously a reason why
the pavement like
i'm only mentioning this now because
it's relevant but there's still concerns
essex police have about this um and
i think that i know when i hear what you
say about the the um
the dimensions i think this comes down a
little bit more than that so
um there's obviously a reason why essex
police are a little bit concerned
um about this uh and i'm going to know
more about it but
i just wanted to mention it again
because i know i asked you about it in
the last uh
hearing um okay
right so if i'm right in thinking then
there's no responsible authority
so interested parties then we'll start
with mr martin if i may
yeah i already made my um
representations about the size of the
area
it is angular you would not fit two
tables of four um
two tables and four chairs in that
recess
so it would spread out onto the pavement
and that's not taken into account
and i mean this genuinely the size of
people sitting on these tables and
chairs
and the fact that these tables and
chairs are movable
so if someone isn't comfortable where
they are they will move out to the
pavement a bit further
um also with regards to
the description of a micropad there is a
magazine which
describes the micro pub as
a very small space which people
affectionate overview
can sit and enjoy their real hour
however they also stipulate
the smaller the better for a micro pub
and i don't see how expanding out onto a
pavement
keeps it small thank you thank you mr
martin
um council butcher
yeah yes thank you chairman um years ago
it used to be you could only put
um anything outside your premises that
was a four
court there is no four court here there
is
a small and i haven't measured it but
it's no more than a foot
um as a recess this will be on the
pavement
the pavement is for pedestrians it's not
that wide it has a lamp post
as well in and outside these premises
as i've stated before with four people
waiting outside the bakers residents
pedestrians were having to walk in the
road
four take four chairs table there's
going to be
other people coming along who may know
them it's encouraged to socialize
this is going to block the pathway and i
think it is
appalling thank you thank you councillor
butcher councillor gooding would you
like to add anything in relation to the
specific
pavement application
the well the main concern is the the
collecting of people and congregating
on the pavement and as with essex police
it will cause
a public nuisance that's why they
refused it
the street furniture placed on the foot
by way
will reduce the access for pedestrians
causing them to have to walk out into
the road
and any of those that have mobility
impaired
or visually impaired people that are
trying to pass this walkway
will also be inconvenienced and put at
risk
so that's a public safety regarding
their accessibility
of this area thank you thank you
councillor gooding
um mr peg
um is there anything you would like to
pick up on what
the uh the other three attendees have
said and would you like to make any um
furnace final submissions regards this
application the paper we'll talk about
the payment license now
yeah just the paper license i know so
yeah i think that
um in in this day and age
i think that there's there's been many
many uh
pavement licenses granted for people to
enjoy
an outside experience i think i can just
uh
err upon um the
the the comment about micro pubs and
spilling out onto the road i think
it isn't really valued it's four chairs
we're talking about
this it's not it's not like i want to
put the whole thing out and
i believe that the correctly positioned
tables and chairs there still would
be uh sufficient access for people to
pass by
so i don't think it's founded to say
that that it's a real intrusion
into that area i've measured it myself
as well stephen greener did
recheck the measuring which i think was
important um
and with the correct positioning of them
it wouldn't encroach into the pavement
too much and still allow people to have
safe passageway
so as i said we've also had
um my discussions with with the essex
police
i know that there is still a concern
that i wasn't maybe aware of quite
rightly but um
when i spoke to them they didn't have a
concern um
it's only four people um so i
i don't think it would be a concern but
and that's all i have to say thank you
mr peg councillor mcfirst and councillor
merrick anything you'd like to
ask mr peg or say before we um move to
the closing
um i'm not sure um chairman if this is
something
for uh mr peg to answer or rather for
our licensing officer
um our um visiting um councillors and
our member of public have mentioned
about people gathering
um around perhaps socializing as they
walk past
now um perhaps our licensing officer can
confirm will it only be people seated
who are able to drink outside
or will people be able to now walk out
of the pub and still hold their
uh drink in their hand to be talking to
people who are walking past
and how will that be policed
i could answer i could speak to that if
that's okay
mr peg yeah it's a very strict condition
actually
um that people would only be able to
consume their alcohol
uh in an open container while seated
outside
people will not be able to take a drink
outside there if they're not seated
and that's something where as a licensee
the license holder and publican that
part of our responsibility
does lie in policing such things and we
have the
we're empowered to actually enforce that
as a licensing republican
which we we would do only drinks that
are in sealed containers are to be
removed from the premises if not to be
drunk
on uh as seated in one of the four
chairs
so no open glasses will be removed from
our premises
unless it's seated and that that is a
strict condition
does it answer your question councilman
ferguson
um would you like further clarification
for mr gregor
thank you chairman um i i would like
further clarification from our licensing
officer because i do have concerns of
how
this will actually be policed in the
real world
um if my friends were sitting outside i
wasn't allowed
i might be tempted to buy a takeaway um
drink
is there anything to stop me actually
drinking that with them
outside perhaps our licensing officer
can explain
so i can ask you a comment mr greene
okay yeah
under the business and planning act it
only refers to the tables and chairs
being placed outside
to encourage people with social
distancing to be seated
so it doesn't talk about allowing
congregation of people standing up only
the seating as it's busy being mentioned
very difficult to patrol and manage
unless there is set conditions
in there in relation to
how they're going to police that and i
believe that essex police have actually
in their alcohol license application
have actually
and i think environment health as well
have actually
put in conditions i know we're crossing
back over to the alcohol license again
but it says customers will not be
permitted to remove
from the premises any alcohol drinks
applied by the premises in open
containers
with exempt with exemption to drinks
provided by the premises to customers
seated at tables
within an area permitted to be used by
the premises
via a valid current premises
uh pavement permission permit so
it is partly conditioned by essex police
and like say and environmental health as
well
so they are enforceable conditions um
that would be down to ourselves to then
enforce in conjunction with the
applicant hopefully that helps
councillor ferson okay thanks chairman
questions councilman
that's fine thank you councillor merrick
yes thank you chairman um i've just got
one
one question i i'd like to ask from
mr greener um i i understand i see from
one of the responses from essex highways
uh that they have raised the points
quite rightly
uh that the um they would not agree to
the footway
at this moment in time being reduced due
to social distancing
and bearing in mind that the relaxation
of the rules relating to
public highways was brought in as a
result
of the cuvid situation it does seem to
me
that social distancing um
is an important factor is
how would you look at that
yes i'd agree um social distancing is a
factor that needs to be taken into
consideration as it's been raised
again within the report um under page
5.21 that essex highways did obviously
have concerns
their email that they originally sent
was based on the original
application of the 12 chairs but they
have said that they would consider the
two
tables and four chairs only outside the
front so
they are happy with that but like i say
it has to be
um with social distancing and they
obviously still
had concerns in relation to the footway
at the end of the day
because as you mentioned the tails and
the chairs could be moved
council uh one second mr peg council
america uh does that answer your
question
um partially uh chairman uh i
i would only make the observation that
the
uh uh response from essex highways
doesn't
in my view
agree to the reduction to two tables and
four
chairs they merely said they would
consider
but then they continued to say that they
would not agree to the footway
at this moment in time being reduced due
to social distancing that was that was
my
that was my query mr greener could you
elaborate at all from what you've
already said that would assist council
america
um yes as you say that it doesn't
specifically
say that they are fully supportive of
the application they would consider
that as a measure as they've also
mentioned within that email
um it talks about smoking areas which
obviously we have discussed
in other areas as well um but
uh it does specifically mention in the
final summing up
paragraph it says i would not agree to
the footway
at this moment in time being reduced due
to social distancing so
yes they have got concerns in relation
to social distancing measures
thank you mr peg i know that you've been
raising your hand to speak um i may i'm
going to ask a question
because it's to do with social
distancing so perhaps you could answer
both what the uh my question and what
the point you want to make at the same
time
and can you explain to us the intended
layout
of these two tables and the four chairs
please i mean
um exactly how you propose to do that
with regards to keeping them
a minimum of two meters apart because my
understanding is at the moment we still
have to be two meters apart don't we
we do and social resistance is something
i take extremely seriously
having gone through this in our existing
establishment the one green bottle
um well first of all we wouldn't be
opening until after the 21st of june
anyway when we would hope that
restrictions would be lifted so we won't
open until then anyway
and secondly we'd have to then obviously
stick to the
all the rules that are in place should
the tables be there now
if it meant that we could only have two
chairs there until the
social distancing rules are relaxed and
that would be the case
um it's something that we take extremely
seriously
you know um hand sanitizer on all tables
is there uh track and trace systems use
the existing one green bottle and that
will continue if necessary
in two green bottles but as i said we
wouldn't be opening until
after the 21st of june anyway where we
hope
that restrictions if if the government
deems it fit
and proper uh restrictions will be
reduced
okay that's fine that answers my
question thank you very much
i hope that answers the other council's
question about the social distancing but
i think that
uh the police um essex highways were
concerned this moment in time would be
correct social distance in place
so their statements correct for this
moment but
may will hopefully be should our uh
covered numbers
continue to reduce as they are and we
becoming in a situation where we're able
to relax
social distancing then it wouldn't be
make it very good after 21st of june
just one last question just referring
back to one other point that was made if
you don't mind
um regarding people socially gathering
outside
just passing i think you'd be you'll
find that people are more
happy to socially gather in a place
where they're not asked to move away
uh more readily because they will be
asked to move if they're standing
outside
especially if they've had if they've
purchased a drink
from not our establishment and they're
not seated they'll be asked to move
and i think people would rather gather
somewhere they're not
told to move generally
did you say they've bought a drink from
elsewhere and are not seated or are
seated i can't stop somebody walking
along the street if they bought a drink
from the co-op
however if they trip if they stop
talking to one of our
our clients sitting at the table then
they'll be asked to move
okay i'm not sure what power you'd have
to do that but i do
understand the sentiment and what you're
saying i know i'd ask the people to move
that are seated
i understand i understand sorry i didn't
make that
clear no no if it's on our license
premises and then purchase drinks from
us if they are socializing with someone
that is drinking on the street
then i would refuse to serve them any
more i can't i'd asked him to leave
thank you more than more within my
rights to do
absolutely so there is one question and
i'm gonna just
quickly jump back into the previous
application as well because there is i
suppose this is relevant for both
and one thing i did mean to ask you as
the applicant
and the license holder how much time do
you intend to spend on the premises and
are you
looking at employing a manager uh on
your behalf
how do you propose to run the premises
we'll certainly
first we'll be spending a great deal of
our time on uh on the premises
it's our premises and our rules but we
will in the future
look to employ a a manager that's
capable of running the premises
if not full-time certainly part-time i
think as i mentioned i
we're an eight-minute drive away so i
intend to spend uh
a fair pulse of our time there okay
thank you
right okay um assuming that council
america mcfirst and don't have any
further questions
um i will move because
america's have to say no
okay you are muted as councillor merrick
but uh i can see the happy smile on your
face i'm assuming it's no
um and i won't forget mr green at this
time
um so i'm now going to come to uh some
final closing submissions from
um the other attendees um in relation
simply
to payment license mr martin i shall
come to you first sir
if you could keep this to a maximum of
two minutes if there's anything you'd
like to summarize in relation to
pavement license
just reiteration about this oh my bigger
problem
just reiterating about the size of the
frontage
two tables two chairs sounds very small
but in a very small area
and i have measured it it is not
feasible
to put that into the recess they will be
on the pavement they will be moved
around
and the size of the furniture which has
also
been mentioned on the application
would lead to a weapon being used should
it need to be
on an escalator escalation of a dispute
and once these tables and chairs are
granted
then there is then reason for further
application forever along the line to
increase
the amount of tables and chairs because
the presidents will have been set
that they're already there so from that
point of view
i most vehemently object to anything
being put over there that stops people
having a safe passage
and when people are drinking they do
become loud they do become very verbal
and to some people that is very
frightening and that cannot be allowed
to happen in my view
thank you thank you mr martin councillor
butcher
come to you next as the ward councillors
anything you'd like to add
in summary
uh i can't add anything other than what
mr martin has said and what i've said
previously
there is not the room outside for even
one table and two chairs
it encourages people to gather whether
you know mr pegg is saying he will uh go
refuse to serve them it still encourages
it
it encourages noise but in most
importantly
it blocks the freeway for pedestrians
thank you
thank you council butcher councillor
gooding
yes likewise my concern is the
obstruction that the
two tables and four chairs will be
uh causing for the pedestrians and for
those that are having
problems with um access
around the premises and then potentially
making these people having to either
cross the road or walk in the road
to get around those that are gathering
and of course it
does add to the noise factor for the
residents that are living above
um with those people talking and
gathering outside
the whole reason that the application
was given the table
the windows and doors to be kept closed
was for the noise factor
when you start putting public outside
the noise will increase and will rise up
to where the people are living
and that is not acceptable in a public
community
thank you councillor gooding mr greener
would you like to make any closing
statements
it's just a very quick summary i think
it might be useful for the members
really and i'm
going to draw your attention to appendix
e which is the the letter that actually
i
i wrote to the applicant um it's just
obviously
we did consult with responsible
authorities and residents
essex police and the russia district
council planning department did raise
concerns along with essex highways
we had lengthy discussions as the group
and after careful consideration
we were looking at the application and
the representations
and we refused the application under the
business and planning act
for the following grounds the group felt
that it should be run as a bar for at
least six months
if an alcohol license was granted to
demonstrate to the residents and
partners
that the venue can run safely and
reassure residents that the outside
seating area would not create additional
noise and concerns
the group felt that the venue should
reapply
under the planning pavement permission
legislation which is the highways act of
1980
once they have completed a bedding in
period of running
the venue in accordance with the
licensing objectives
and that's the end of the summary thank
you
okay where are we so
thank you very much um i believe uh
and sonia chris i'm looking to you to
correct me if i have this wrong i
believe that's the end
of the evidence stage
yes good okay um in that case then
um the committee will now adjourn and we
will consider
case and we'll consider everything we've
heard from all parties present
and i can't give you an approximate time
how long this will take because
we want to give it sufficient time so
that we listen to everything
and um we we can see everything i should
say
um and we come to the what we believe to
be the right decision
um this decision will be we will
announce the decision we will come back
uh into this
forum to announce decision but it will
also be sent to the applicant
um by writing none of you have to wait
but of course you're welcome to do so
okay so i i now the time
is 11 25 so this hearing is now
uh concluded sorry
should we stay on this this call i
believe there was another
meeting invite for the conclusion
for the decision there is yes how's that
going to work sonia are we going to
email everybody
yes so chairman um we will then we will
liaise with the licensing officer
when we're actually ready to uh
recommend reconvene
um once uh you've deliberated and that
will be the um
the final set of joining instructions
that everyone has
okay right everybody happy would they
understand what's going to happen from
here on in mr martin
so um we'll be receiving an email to
tell us the later
start time for you're here for mr
greener you'll hear